hi there Steve Kaufman here it's the  beginning of a new year 2023  uh a time you make resolutions what  we're gonna do in the New Year New  Year's resolutions we set some goals  um you know I want to talk a bit about  goals here it's fine to have a big goal  I want to be fluent in Spanish or  Chinese or I want to understand the  movies goals are fine it kind of you  know it's a vision of where you want to  get to but having the goal isn't going  to get you there  is more important to have short-term you  know targets it's more about habits  processes what are you going to do every  day how are you going to develop the  habits that get you studying that  language every day that's going to get  you there not the long-term fuzzy goal  but the daily habits the daily targets  the 90-day challenge that we have at  link so focus on your targets your